I'm Sharon Oster economics and
management at the Yale School of
Management where I have been had the
pleasure for many years of having Doug
gray as my esteemed and Valley College I
am so pleased today to be able to
introduce him to all of you I know we
had a lavish introduction yesterday so
I'm gonna be short dub is giving today
the second amount is three Stimson
lectures based on his book a book with
an intriguing title and I will make sure
I get it right capitalism knowledge
drives well and that's a a lot in one
title for all of us this is an ambitious
book job has been working on for some
years and I think we're all very excited
that it has come to fruition in the form
of these lectures today the title is
especially intriguing to me as an
economist today's title is when markets
force learning America in the 19th
century so where's it go let me just say
when I first met Doug if he came fresh
from the political science department
I'm not sure he would have ever thought
markets were forcing anything very good
so I completely intrigued to hear
perhaps he's changed his mind over the
years or perhaps the title is just meant
to intrigue me so please join me in
welcoming John he will give his third
lecture tomorrow and I expect
I've double-crossed you I today's this
real lecture is on what the founders got
wrong and tomorrow is about markets I
pushed that off as long as possible
in actual fact I quite like markets I
I will even quote Hayek at some point so
we we didn't quite finish lecture one
and I'm going to just review the the
last little bit of that today but let me
review the idiosyncratic parts of the
way I'm labeling things by the green
period
I mean 1400 to 1750 when all kinds of
wonderful intellectual and cultural
things happened the Renaissance
Reformation the Enlightenment and not
much happened to the planet so the
planet gets to 1750 without yet having
been greatly damaged by human
intervention and that the green period
is a kind of platform from which the
very rapid development which happened in
Western Europe and North America in the
last three centuries got off to a
favored start in many ways perhaps more
favorable than it deserved this is the
fresh planet in 1750 as I imagine it
with a contemporary slide this is co2 in
the atmosphere the green box represents
my idea of of the green period which
since the scale here is 800,000 years
I've drawn it a little bigger than then
it would just Li have been
on green period and the beliefs which
were thoughtful minted by the
Enlightenment that prosperity and health
are up to us not God God skepticism was
rampant among the American founders
almost none of them were literal
Christians the natural world is ours to
understand and to conquer technology
changes slowly that that's how it was in
the green period it was going to start
changing a whole lot faster by about
1750 and dilution will cure pollution
the planet if you just throw in a river
it would go away and not be seen again
one consequence of that was that delay
and deadlock in government was seen as a
fairly benign outcome
the one person who among the founders
who understood that it wasn't benign and
would become far less benign with time
was Alexander Hamilton and not unusual
Hamilton was way ahead of his times
intellectually and I think he actually
gets underpaid in most of the histories
of that period we talked about
capitalism having five definitive
features though within the framework of
national government private ownership of
the means of production mostly the
interest behind the companies managing
the means of production enjoy very wide
latitude in what they produce how they
produce it and whom they employ for that
purpose labor is free
in the sense that in the sense that it
is not enslaved and in the sense that it
is free to choose among employers but
not in the sense that it is empowered to
choose the terms on which it is employed
from a blank slate free is a bird to
mock our usage of the term free labor
and finally an important part of the
capitalist apparatus is a system of
research institutions and universities
and schools and indeed from my point of
view the most the firmest and most
important basis of lasting wealth is
practical knowledge the most obvious
cases are ones where you're on the on
the frontier technologically but the
accumulation of practical knowledge
generation to generation is at the core
of my own thinking here are the
following consequences of taking the
capitalist road sharply increased
civility affluence and sometimes wealth
smart and we looked at some quirky data
about IQ and what I have in mind is more
high axe idea about dispersed wealth a
dispersed wealth of knowledge where no
one person group or firm knows any major
fraction of a society's total common
wealth of knowledge and depends on a
trust relationship with others who own
that knowledge more directly dirt
meaning pollution and degradation of the
natural world has been a leading
concomitant
capitalism there's no way around that as
a fact insecurity about income is a big
part of life below the midpoint in a
capitalist economy and I made the point
yesterday that the last people you
should listen to on this topic are
senior members of university faculties
who are used to fifty year contract and
let's get on with it here this is Hayek
Sharron I promised and the idea he's
putting forward is one that I believe
wholeheartedly the more society as a
whole knows the lower is the fraction of
that which any one individual is going
to command so we are all in a position
of reliance on knowledge communicated by
others often very indirectly when we buy
an electric toaster and you can get a
perfectly decent one at Walmart last I
checked for $12 plus sales tax and the
the likelihood that anyone in this room
would know how to put together an
electric toaster from scratch is I think
zero does anybody anybody want to stand
as the exception I think it's pretty
pretty certain that it's zero I'm sure
that in my own case it is zero the tail
end of of yesterday's discussion had to
do with insecurity and outright poverty
and I just want to look at four or five
slides to complete that we the people
this is the Constitutional Convention
those are fine fine gentlemen in the
best
of available attire probably a little
sweated up from the summer heat of
Philadelphia but they were if anything
not the people they were a narrow elite
drawn from across the 13 colonies they
would be if not the 1% they would be in
somewhere but the 90th percentile in the
way of material comforts and the people
meaning the great mass of persons living
in the colonies would not have been
eligible even to vote
half of them because they were female
and the rest because they did not own
substantial property the property
franchise was a radical restriction
worldwide among among the early
Republic's which and and the word
democracy among the founders was a two
edged word and more often than not was
used as a signal of danger and bad
judgment democracy was and not what they
were aiming for they were aiming for
republicanism on a fairly restricted
franchise these this is a Press quote
from a year ago about the insecurity of
many American households and the special
likelihood that households headed by
women would be near the precipice of
impoverishment on a regular basis risk
of hunger or food insecurity this is an
article saying things are getting better
after 2008 2009 to
but not a lot better
the percentage of American households
who were food insecure is dipping down
toward the right this is a finding in
Jacob hackers work here at Yale 6% of
American families in any two-year period
can expect to lose half or more of their
income that's a stunning number right
half your income is a catastrophic
change and six percent makes it not
terribly rare so an in Shapiro and Mike
rats have a book which we will see in
the next year entitled the wolf at the
door and it's about the centrality of
that phenomenon for much of American
society
if 6% have that experience far more than
6% have to worry about it have to
contemplate it as a possibility perhaps
a third of American households have a
realistic reason to believe that they
might fall off the edge economically in
any given period this is a this is from
the Federal Reserve two years ago they
put out a report in which people leaning
to the left interpreter as follows 40%
of American citizens could not raise
$400 to meet an unexpected emergency and
it turns out that's an exaggeration what
this is a clarification from Bloomberg
last summer from her from Michael strain
I'm committing the big sin of putting
200 words on the on the screen and then
reading them to you I'll summarize
briefly it is 39% could pay in cash
could go to their bank account or tin
box and produce the cash to meet the
$400
61% would have to rely on the use of
credit or or or death so that's still a
pretty strong statement but it's not
quite the statement that Elizabeth
Warren and others have been using on the
stump in the last few months end of
lecture 1 slides all right what the
founders got wrong this is North America
as it looked around 1750 largely largely
undeveloped in the way capitalist
occupation develops land largely in the
hands of Native Americans thinly
populated but clustered in fair numbers
along the east coast where they would
encounter the European arrivals
beginning around 1600 with the Virginia
Company the orange band on the coast of
course is what became the United States
and what was derived largely from
British grants of grants to
organizations like the Virginia Company
the Massachusetts Bay Company and New
Haven colony which lasted only from 1637
till 1665 when it was on the verge of
bankruptcy
so look at that beautiful scene with a
Harvest Moon and the capital and Old
Glory and the question is what could go
wrong and here are things which
regularly go wrong they're not
catastrophic but they do go wrong
Washington dysfunction damaging national
security
that's a budgetary question and I don't
think it means that any any military
officers or enlisted personnel were
killed but it means that the overall
functioning of National Defense is made
more difficult when the Congress cannot
produce budgetary outcomes in a prompt
an orderly way the story with the
conflict over the Trump the Trump border
wall and the appropriation for it is too
familiar to bear repetition so and I
will by the end of the lecture develop
examples of more substantial challenges
where the endless delay and endless
intrigue in the functioning of our
national government is of vital
importance going forward so we have the
13 colonies here all adjacent to the
Atlantic and nearly all are involved in
disputes about control over Western land
and the economic value of that western
land is at the time of the Constitution
still low because the land is largely in
excess of
Overland Overland transport is
prohibitively expensive and extremely
risky the the capital development of the
country will attack that pretty promptly
by 1825 one generation after the
Constitution the Erie Canal will be
completed and will allow freight traffic
to go up the Hudson River to Albany and
from Albany West all the way to Buffalo
and with Buffalo a water access for
eight or nine months of the year to the
Great Lakes opening up what became the
Ohio territory and what we think of as
the Midwestern heartland this is the
census of 1790 the first census and it's
a remarkable document Jefferson was
administratively in charge of it as
Secretary of State
Hamilton was more directly engaged in it
because he saw it as a very important
document for persuasion it contains it
has built-in patriarchy and racial
racially based slavery
slaves are enumerated separately and
women are enumerated separately and
males are divided at age 16 between
those over 16 and those under and that's
a there's some insight in that age split
well the the distribution of slaves is
quite uneven more or less corresponds
with latitude distance from the equator
the by
colonies in red were 25% or more slave
the yellow ones New York and New Jersey
were around five six percent slaves the
others were thinly populated with slaves
and Massachusetts did not formally admit
to having any you don't need this slide
if you look at the right the column in
red it tells you what the median age of
the country was if the percentage under
16 is right about 50 percent the median
age was surely 16 or 16 point zero
something and that's an interesting fact
I think for a minute about countries
that have a median age of 16 right now
there are some
that that it's a demographic fact about
a young a young society such societies
are are always plagued by high death
rates and high birth rates people are
living relatively short lives on average
and young men the most dangerous
fraction of our species are men from
about I don't know I look out here at
Yale students and I think no not that
dangerous but in actual fact and I think
this stands up across space and across
history men under 30 men who are
biologically mature but under 30 are the
most dangerous creatures among us and I
have no demography on this event the
Boston Tea Party but it seems more than
plausible to me that the guys dressed up
as Indians throwing the merchandise in
the water were not Ben Franklin and his
peers but robust young men with animal
spirits running through their veins
Lexington and Concord depicted here in a
primitive primitive drawing is the
opening of the American Revolution it's
not clear to this day who fired the
first shot
there was no national national military
for the u.s. at the time of election
encounter court these were local milk
local militias fighting the Redcoats who
were the real deal of the British crown
it was a largely a standoff but it began
a process of mobilization which was
resolved ultimately with the treaty
Treaty of Paris in 1783 the government
of the not-so united states appointed
George Washington General of the army of
which there was none and he was governed
by the Articles of Confederation adopted
formally in well adopted initially in
1777 rockslide in 1777 ratified only in
1781 the same year that the war ended as
a real war that is the the time at which
the General Cornwallis surrendered the
bulk of the Royal Army at Yorktown in
1781 will come to that momentarily
Eisenhower I mean Eisenhower
think of that General Washington was
continuously short of funding short of
conscripts conscripts were recruited
often on very short enlistment as short
as 12 months he was without without any
supply chain most of the time when they
were encamped in the winter at Valley
Forge
they were requisitioning calories and
fuel by force and had no no organized
supply chain well this is representation
of Valley Forge the part lower-left
where the men are huddled around a fire
is suggestive these are the articles in
black and white this is a contract
between sovereign nations or nations or
colonies which wish to assert their
independence from one another and from
the Brits it's a specific contract with
limited purposes each colony each state
got one vote within the Confederacy so
that Virginia and New York which were
pretty big were on an equal footing with
Rhode Island for example wit or Georgia
which were both in those days really
quite small there is no executive branch
there is no method of enforcing
compliance even when by unanimous vote
the thirteen
colonies agree on something so this is
one step short of anarchy and it is a
very hard way to win a war here's
Hamilton Hamilton was acutely aware that
this system didn't work and he knew why
if you if you require unanimity or
anything close to it you put all the
leverage in the hands of negative
minorities all the real leverage was in
on the side of colonies which didn't
wish to sign up for whatever was being
proposed and most typically what was
being proposed was an increase in in
taxes and costs or a a provision of
young men suitable for the army Anton
saw the logic of that being leading as
we say as we hear him say here hands
tedious delays continual negotiation and
intrigue contemptible compromises of the
public good and the Constitutional
Convention ameliorated that but didn't
cure it let me stop and confess right
now I think the United States would be
better governed if we had a
parliamentary system comparable to
Canada or Great Britain I don't think
it's going to happen
in fact it's it's if you stop and think
about what what the cable cable news
networks would be like they'd love this
it would be just hilarious this is this
is a much later representation of the
battle at Yorktown and in particular
salient number 10 in the British British
fort fortification was overrun by a
combination of American and French
troops led by of all people Alexander
Hamilton he was out there with a musket
and a must well they it's interesting
they carried muskets but they didn't
give the troops any ammunition they
withheld the ammunition and said fix the
bayonets what you're gonna do is stand
these people and that turned out to be
what they did they did not fire they
just ran up the slope and attacked with
the bayonets and they got a pretty quick
surrender by that method this is the
formal surrender Cornwallis is shown
here on his white horse and this is John
Trumbull fiction Cornwallis as it turns
out didn't show up for the surrender
claiming to be ill and the the Trumbull
painting is painted from imagination
here is you saw this a few minutes ago
this is a constitutional convention in
an air-conditioned room
in a hot sweltering Philadelphia and
though I criticize the defensive aspect
of our Constitution they were remarkable
people and gathering of there were at
least 20 of these people who were off
the charts in the way of intelligence
and diligence and willingness to see a
project through even when it was
difficult going on impossible they kept
they didn't had they didn't insist on
unanimity
but they kept a great many defensive
measures to make it feasible to prevent
a majority seeking change from
prevailing they were not negotiating a a
somewhat stronger agreement between
independent colonies they were turning
themselves into provinces of a new
entity Virginia would become a province
of the United States and so would all
the other colonies so this was a
momentous decision and a hazardous one
and the convention acted with with fear
of the hazards the fear in particular
that a majority of foreigners people
from other colonies now other provinces
of the new state without vote them and
by out voting them would deprive them of
their wealth and
now now let's do a mental experiment for
a minute and imagine a new country
forming now with those prospective
provinces and with their eighty I make
up the the delegations on a pro-rata
basis from population they add up to
eighty in total the United States has 33
Haiti has but one Venezuela three etc
now the question for you as the American
delegate or more fancifully the American
president that's really him
the American president contemplating
this question how many votes should be
required in the unicameral legislature
of this new country to put it put
forward a change in any major policy
about the country and I suggest that
here's a likely thought process imagine
that coalition which is a majority it's
I think forty two of eighty votes and
then make this calculation eighty minus
the u.s. equals forty seven require more
than forty seven perhaps forty eight
votes to change anything make it a very
defensive Constitution I think most of
us would arrive at just about that
calculation
given the far-fetched example I've
produced and that's pretty much how
these people thought about this
Madison understood that majorities had
special status in a republic notice
these were not necessarily majorities of
the whole population but of the whole
male property population they took that
to be the general way of Republic's and
they didn't like what it implied they
didn't like living with the risk of
being on the losing side of major
questions about the distribution of
costs and benefits across the different
parts of society where the parts are
thought of first as states but could
instead be thought of as economic
interests for example the infant
industries of Greater Boston which had a
powerful stake in being rewarded with
tariffs and bounties to make it possible
for them to compete against better
established and superior competitors on
the other side of the Atlantic or
farmers in in Pennsylvania or
slaveholders in Georgia or the Carolinas
or Virginia they all were vulnerable and
understood themselves to be vulnerable
to dangerous majorities and they took
great pains to restrain majority rule
this is Jill Lepore let me do a survey
how many of you have read some Jill
Lepore I admonished the rest of you to
do more of that she's the best writer of
nonfiction English practice
in the United States right about now and
has a has a fat history of the United
States called these truths it runs about
800 pages and I've read it and learned a
lot
her metaphor is she's here she's
channeling Madison she is giving the
thought process which she imagines
Madison and his colleagues to be going
through what force restrains good men
from doing bad things
honesty character religion these history
demonstrates were not to be relied upon
no the only force that could restrain
the tyranny of of the people was the
force of a well-constructed Constitution
it would have have to be as finely
wrought as an iron gate and an iron gate
is what they thought they were putting
together and and in many respects it is
still good it's probably better metal
than I then wrought iron it's more like
steel Federalist 10 this is Madison who
was a tiny man this painting somehow
makes him look like a big guy he was 5'4
and probably weighed a hundred and ten
and the theme of Federalist 10 a fairly
famous essay is that if you make the
country big it will be heterogeneous and
because it is heterogeneous it will be
difficult for people to put together
majority coalition's that was closer to
true in 1787 than it is today
and the technological communications
changes in transportation and
communication which happened mainly by
1900
much undermine the Federalist 10-story
help
oh wait here we are here's Matt Madison
again the aim is to is to divide and
arrange the several offices in such a
manner that each may be a check on all
the others so checks and balances
constant constant eyes looking
horizontally across Massachusetts Avenue
or Pennsylvania Avenue all this stuff is
familiar and my guess is that those of
you who grew up in the states could
recite that the slide I have up now by
the time you were in eighth grade states
right is I was interviewing in Baker
County Georgia in connection with this
project a year ago I'm talking to a guy
named Mike Lanier who runs a rural
garage whose main business is servicing
agricultural tractors servicing tractors
and replacing tractor tires out in the
field he makes a pretty good living
doing it and we're riding along in his
truck and he queries me what do you
think the Civil War was about and I say
slavery and he's a no sir it was about
states rights and he then has a sermon
that goes with that and it's not an
entirely silly silly or disingenuous a
story it's what this guy believes in
that same conversation he
told me that his great-grandfather had
been interned by the Yankees and at the
end of the war found himself at Camp
Douglas Illinois and was forced to walk
home to southern Georgia it's about 600
miles and was perfectly happy to do it
that he and I had a friendly
relationship but I would not say it was
trustful I don't think he thought I was
with him in every detail hey Carl what
do you think what am I doing there okay
this is another way of summarizing some
of the restraining factors we have today
it's hard it's very hard to move
anything big complicated and
consequential through the American
legislative process though they just say
the legislative process is only half
over
when Congress passes the law and the
president signs it because after that
the the detail think about this
Obamacare Act was 2400 printed pages and
it was that long partly because they
gave the opportunity for dozens if not a
hundred maybe a hundred maybe more than
a hundred different interest groups to
insert clauses and paragraphs favoring
their members the only way you could
possibly have gotten this piece of a
piece of legislation through the
Congress was by accumulating deals with
almost everybody that's part of why it
is an
almost it is a very inefficient scheme
by the time it's here I'm a big fan of
the fact that they got it done at all
but I don't really think they got it
done
satisfactorily or anywhere close to that
we are even with the Affordable Care Act
as it is called we are right at 18% of
gross national product for health care
and we have health results which are
middle-of-the-pack for advanced
countries actually below
middle-of-the-pack we are we are
embarrassingly poor on an embarrassingly
rich budget
here are four four topics that I think
have to be faced by the federal
government in your generation I'm
speaking to those of you who are vastly
younger than me and that's a good
fraction of you carbon the process of
restricting carbon in the Senate today
that it was announced that a bipartisan
group of senators have formed the a
Climate Change caucus meaning they will
raise money for themselves and meet once
in a while probably not meaning that
they will muscle something through and
it won't be it will be nigh on
impossible I think about think about
Bill Nordhaus our own bill Nordhaus
Nobel laureate Nordhaus who is who has
worked for 30 years on the carbon
problem and he has a pretty
straightforward proposal which is to tax
carbon and the idea would be that each
each
country that has industrial waste should
be taxing carbon hard enough that
companies figure out how to use a lot
less carbon to get done the same things
they do now the obvious ones have to do
with trucks and cars passenger airplanes
heating buildings and we are all
profligate consumers of carbon consuming
it is not the bad part wasting it up the
chimney or out the tailpipe is the
problem and the chart we looked at
yesterday and skimmed briefly today
tells it a menacing story well let's try
this I the only way to have an an
anonymous survey in a room like this is
instead of raising hands to home and so
I'll ask I will do - hums one is I
believe that unchecked climate change
would be disastrous
please hum
I don't really believe it
it sounds unanimous that's a little too
good to be true in any group this size I
believe it and and I think we are very
ill-equipped politically to carry out
your will as expressed with those
columns health care is the is a parallel
story it is for the society at large
less menacing than climate change but
for individuals who are sick it is far
more dramatic and far more immediate
individuals who are sick and uninsured
and again I think we are ill-equipped
what's the founders what the founders
did did not contemplate K Street in
Washington K Street in Washington where
thousands of extremely well-educated
extremely well paid lawyers represent
existing interests threatened by the
changes we're talking about and they're
really good at blocking and deflecting
and inducing others to do that on their
behalf the it's an interesting exercise
to go through the list of interest
groups that have formal representation
in Washington the poultry Association of
America for example is a huge and
formidable organization and there is a
poultry caucus in the Senate and another
one in the house and you can guess where
they're where their memberships in
Congress come mainly come from we are
we've gone from chicken as a special
treat for Sunday dinner
a midday meal - something purchasable
for less than a dollar or maybe a little
more than a dollar in a fast-food
restaurant for consumption on an
everyday and for some people it seems
nearly every our basis
immigration we are a phase for
demography the United States meaning
this we are predominantly the median age
is about 40 but the number of people who
like me our past normal working age is
high and getting higher and the so
called dependency ratio is how what
fraction of the Papa country is between
20 and 64 that is nominally of
employment age because the the
productive activity that sustains the
whole country comes largely from that
age group and when that age group is a
diminishing fraction of the total that's
a big problem and the reason the
countries that have this problem most
acutely are Japan much of Europe in
Japan it is most pronounced because they
don't encourage widespread emigration
the United States
if we're gonna going to adjust to our
demographic condition needs immigrants
who have babies if we need from a
demographic point of view exactly what
President Trump wants us not to have
which is a large number of often brown
skinned young people and that adjustment
is not going to be an easy one but I
think the democra the demographic story
in this country is under played in the
press we very seldom see it in USA today
in such places but it is a very major
fact about our generational future and
then gun control I have no hope that we
will get the number of guns out there
under 300 million I don't think that can
happen I think that it's politically
infeasible indeed I think coercively
taking weapons away from American
citizens would require a constitutional
amendment and a political movement of
immense proportions sustained over a
period of decades and there is no
evidence that that's going to happen now
living with gun violence up to and
including a fairly frequent mass murder
is a deplorable condition for any
country that you know the Soviet Union
was not great at inventing wonderful
consumer products in fact they were
famously not great at it
they were very bad at it they were good
at inventing military weapons the
kalisch decoff rifle is the model for
the ak-47 that until recently you could
buy at Walmart and the idea that
actually had yelled student we were
talking about this he said yes I own one
and I was just stunned to silence and
it's fairly rare than on really fun
but he then told me a story about how he
thought of it as a way to protect his
sister and all right you know what can I
say I can't can't argue with him
maybe there's a real danger and maybe a
machine gun is the right answer but I
don't really think so
do it how many of you own guns yeah I I
own a gun and have a permit to carry it
it may have expired and I haven't taken
the it's a pistol I haven't taken it out
of the safe in two or three years and I
think my wife if I if we had a vote half
a half of the adults in our household
would vote to throw it in a river am i
right on that's not so and I have never
shot at any person or living creature
well there's lots out there for the
government to do
I personally actually believe that
there's a lot of there is a lot of bad
regulation in our economy much of it by
the way created at the behest of the
regulated industries Koch Industries had
a the penny dropped for them about 15
years ago
and they realized that certain
regulations work strongly to their
advantage and they quietly support those
regulations indeed many manufacturing
companies like Cummins engine for
example which holds the patents on the
cleanest diesel engines being
manufactured in America or in China for
Americans and they see the regulations
as a way of come
telling others to get out of the come
out of the markets that they dominate
because the expense of meeting the high
standard will make the activity
unprofitable for others who haven't made
the investment already and they're
perfectly happy that I don't think they
would like to make a press announcement
about this but they come here and talk
about their business once a year and
this is part of what they say so by way
of concluding Hamilton Hamilton whom
we'll talk about at the beginning of
beginning of lecture 3 again began his
his report on manufacturers written
and/or
submitted to Congress in December of
1791 he began that by working with a guy
named tenth ten stocks to engage in
industrial espionage to hire spies to go
to England and work in the textile mills
at Manchester and memorize and report
out specific details about the
engineering of the machinery by which
the Brits were then making cotton
cheaper and better than anyone in North
America could make it cotton garments he
saw industrial knowledge as the key to
the American future and he was right I
mean the colonial routine for the Brits
was to have
North American colonies producing raw
materials selling them to the Brits at
relatively low prices and buying
manufactured articles created by the
Brits from those raw materials at a
great profit to them to the metropolitan
country and Hamilton's thought he grew
up in a Caribbean store in a port on a
small island in the Caribbean his
thought was well he'll know let's get in
the manufacturing business the Brits
created an embargo not allowing
machinery advanced machinery to be sold
outside Great Britain and attempting to
keep people with work experience in the
textile industry from emigrating a guy
named Samuel Slater was the very smart
kid who tech tench Cox hired to memorize
the workings of Richard Arkwright
machinery for manufacturing cotton goods
and Slater mills in Rhode Island was one
of the results of that but a hundred or
two hundred other manufacturing
companies were also gotten going with
that knowledge and stolen knowledge
which that was is not the best kind of
knowledge knowledge created through
trial and error and effort is a better
kind of knowledge and was the ultimate
aim Hamilton had in mind will continue
those of you who are able to come
tomorrow will continue from there with a
more upbeat story about American
prosperity
[Applause]
yeah if there are some of you will need
to leave but others can we can talk a
bit about objections or queries I can't
see out there
pee-yew things cut going forward you
mean as a challenge or as a consequence
of capitalism I mean there is a story
that two countries which are both market
economies very seldom fight each other
in a war world war two would be a
conspicuous exception ok it's ok more
seriously my answer is I just think it's
a preeminent threat to capitalism but to
civilization yeah I agree with that you
might say Jean that is so stupid for you
to think we could do anything about it I
just think that an old guy like myself
should have hope and confidence enough
to speak out and even a kid like you
well yeah I mean I read that president
Trump announced that we have an epochal
epoch-making agreement with Syria and
the Kurds engineered by vice-president
pence and secretary
Pompeyo as of today I think it may be
there may be a certain amount of
than that but no and I piece the notion
of of even limited war with technical
capacity that modern nation-states most
of all the United States possess is
pretty nearly unthinkable and the one
impulse that Trump seems to have
actually has two that I think are
somewhat redemptive one of them is that
I think he I think he has never I I
think this is true I don't think he has
used an aggressive military move to win
an argument or or curry favor with
voters during his thousand plus days I
think that's true I nobody have a
contrary view of that the other one is I
think he was right that our economic
relation with China needed work maybe
not the work he's been doing what work
yes Jeff I don't know what this lecture
have to do with capitalism since it was
mostly about the decentralized and
anarchic self-defeating government which
as you know I think well I would say it
doesn't have anything to do with
after this and I mean Samuel Huntington
one of his great articles was that it
was a takeover from the tudor
constitution of England and it's about
republicanism which goes back to the
Middle Ages so well it for me it has
this the certainly Hamilton saw what he
was doing as he didn't use the the
c-word but his his vision in report on
manufacturers in much of his political
career and in the Society for the
encouragement of useful knowledge which
he founded all those were about creating
the knowledge basis of a manufacturing
economy and the manufacturing economy
has created a country not at all
designed for this Constitution that's
what makes it interesting to me as in a
relationship to capitalism that it's a
pretty good question and it's a
pertinent question Robert Gordon at
Northwestern he's an economist has a
book and it's now two or three years old
called the rise and fall of American
growth by which he means economic growth
and what he shows is that for roughly a
hundred years after the Civil War
America had a vigorously
expanding growth generating economy and
since about 1979 or 1975 the rate of
expansion has decreased sharply so we're
not talking about it growing and then
getting smaller we're talking about it
growing fast and then growing slower so
it's the rate of change in the rate of
growth that he's writing about and he is
for me extremely persuasive
I have asked some people who know their
economics a whole lot better than I do
what they think and they tend to agree
that the slowing growth story is what
fits the current data better than any
other account of recent American years I
think one part of that is that we have
created a very comfortable management
class in the country and share buybacks
for example don't expand the economy
what they expand is the market price of
company shares and a great many top
management people have contracts
rewarding them in proportion to the
upward movement of company shares and I
think I if I knew how to manipulate
growth and more important maybe the
ratio between growth and dirt the amount
of dirt per unit of growth that's the
most important of a ratio as I can
imagine
out there that's a long way of saying I
I really don't know yeah top companies
it hasn't felt it down to the working
class over the last 20 years that's a
very good point and there is a brand new
book which I heartily recommend called
the triumph of injustice which is a
these guys are French so they're given
the strong language but they are this
guy Emanuel saves I say easy is as good
a student of income distributions in
advanced economies as walks anywhere on
the planet and I'm plowing through this
I don't revise my slides for tomorrow if
I find new new points that I had
previously neglected
[Applause]
[Music]